felipe alimenta a su perro con la misma
cantidad cada día de una bolsa grande de
alimento para perro dos semanas después
de abrir por primera vez la bolsa él
decide comenzar a pensar cuánto alimento
queda en la bolsa cada semana aquí están
sus datos vemos que después de 14 días
quedan 14 kilogramos y cuando pasan
otros 7 días es decir ya pasaron 21 días
desde que abrió la bolsa solo quedan 10
puntos 5 kilogramos después de 28 días
quedan siete kilogramos vamos a usar
esta información para responder a
algunas preguntas interesantes al mismo
tiempo que lo visualizamos en una
gráfica lo primero que podemos hacer es
tratar de calcular cuánto alimento había
en la bolsa cuando la abrieron
suponiendo que felipe usa la misma
cantidad de alimento cada semana pausa
en el vídeo y traten de calcular cuánto
alimento había en la bolsa al inicio si
suponemos que felipe le da a su perro la
misma cantidad de alimento cada semana
hay varias formas de resolver esto para
ayudarnos a visualizarlo vamos a tratar
de dibujar una gráfica usando los datos
que tenemos y luego trataremos de ver
qué es lo que sucede conforme nos
acercamos al inicio de esto y quizá
también veamos qué es lo que sucede al
final este es el eje x este es el eje y
en el eje x vamos a poner el número de
días transcurridos y en el eje y vamos a
poner el alimento restante que está en
kilogramos veamos la escala vertical es
de 5 10 15 20 y 25 creo que es
suficiente y con respecto a los días
queremos llegar hasta los 28 días y
parece que la escala es semanal así que
el eje x es de 7 14 21 y 28 aquí nos dan
estos datos después de 14 días quedan 14
kilogramos el punto en la gráfica queda
más o menos por acá
después de 21 días quedan 10 punto 5
kilogramos más o menos por aquí y
después de 28 días quedan 7 kilogramos
que están por acá y suponemos que la
tasa de consumo de alimento es constante
que le da al perro la misma cantidad de
alimento cada semana por lo que esto
describe una recta en la que la tasa
será la pendiente de esa recta y si
podemos graficar esta recta ubicando los
puntos en donde intersec aa los ejes xy
podremos saber otras cosas más voy a
tratar de dibujar una recta con esta
herramienta para conectar los puntos
digamos que luce más o menos así esta es
la recta que describe cómo se consume el
alimento vamos a asegurarnos de que
todos los puntos están en la recta
trataremos de responder la primera
pregunta y pensemos en cómo podríamos
hacerlo cuánto alimento había en la
bolsa al inicio qué punto aquí
representa la cantidad inicial de
alimento
es la cantidad que queda en el día cero
se trata de este punto de acá el que
describe cuánto alimento había en la
bolsa al inicio es la intersección en jr
la intersección en que nos indica cuál
es el valor de y cuando el valor
horizontal es 0 y observando la gráfica
parece que es un poco mayor a 20 pero
podemos calcular el valor exacto al
pensar en la pendiente se refiere a la
tasa en la que se reduce la cantidad de
alimento podemos ver que cada semana que
pasa o cada 7 días se usan tres y medio
kilogramos otra forma de pensar en esto
es que cada dos semanas se consumen
siete kilogramos así que cada 14 días el
alimento disminuye 7 kilogramos si
queremos encontrar este valor exacto
tenemos que verlo al revés si regresamos
14 días entonces va a aumentar 7
kilogramos la cantidad de alimento y
este es el punto 0 21 así que cuánto
alimento había en la bolsa cuando la
abrió felipe habían 21 kilogramos esto
lo obtuvimos de la intersección en jeff
otra pregunta sería cuánto alimento le
dá felipe a su perro cada día pausa en
el vídeo y trate
responder lo sabemos que cada 14 días le
da a su perro 7 kilogramos una forma de
pensar en esto es que al observar la
pendiente y ver la tasa a la que
alimenta a su perro la pendiente es
igual al cambio en jim menos 7
kilogramos cada vemos el cambio en x
cada 14 días 7 entre 14 es igual a un
medio por lo que esto es igual a menos
medio kilogramo por día esto nos dice
que cada día la cantidad de alimento que
queda disminuye en medio kilogramo por
lo que es suponemos que le da a su perro
y que su perro come medio kilogramo al
día y podemos responder otra pregunta
cuántos días durará la bolsa como lo
resolverían sabemos que estará más o
menos por acá si continuamos con la
recta porque en este punto donde la
recta inter seca al eje x que es la
intersección en x estará el valor de x
que corresponde a ye igual a 0 y se
indica cuánto alimento queda indica cuál
será el día en el que ya no quede
alimento
podemos tratar de estimar lo o podemos
calcular lo con exactitud sabemos que
cada 14 días se consumen 7 kilogramos de
alimento por lo que si estamos en 7
kilogramos como lo estamos aquí y
avanzamos 14 días en el futuro se
terminará lo que quedaba de alimento en
la bolsa así que sumamos 14 días en los
que se terminan los 7 kilogramos que
quedaban esto ocurre después de los 28
días de aquí por lo que este es el día